أريد أن أنتقل الآن إلى العميد المتقاعد في الجيش الأمريكي
مارك كيميت عند
الجدار السحري للجنرال الأمريكي كيميت ليخبرنا
عن هذا التهديد المحيط المحتمل
من أه دول أخرى في المنطقة أه أين
يقف هذا الآن نعم
أعتقد أه أننا بحاجة إلى  كن كما قال أورين،
انظر إلى بعض التهديدات الأخرى
المحتملة لإسرائيل إذا تم اجتياحها
للقتال إذا ألقيت نظرة على أه
الدولة المحيطة بإسرائيل الآن
فأنت تتحدث أيضًا عن أه
مسلحين محتملين هنا في سوريا
حزب الله اللبناني في هذه المنطقة بالتأكيد
قد تكون هناك بعض المخاوف بشأن
خروج الفلسطينيين من الضفة الغربية
ولا يزال هناك
تهديد من تنظيم القاعدة هنا في غزة، لذا أه أسوأ
شيء ممكن لهذا هو أن يتم
سحب تلك التهديدات العسكرية إلى
هذه المعركة والآن لديك  إسرائيل
محاصرة بالكامل كجزء من
العملية العسكرية وماذا عن
التهديدات المحتملة خارج المنطقة
نعم هذا سؤال جيد جدًا
كذلك أه التهديدات أكثر دبلوماسية
منها أه عسكرية كل المخاطر
على العمل الذي تم إنجازه على
العامين الماضيين
نعم هناك قتال صغير يجري
هنا في غزة، لديك قلق بشأن
التهديدات العسكرية هناك ولكن
كل ما حاولت الولايات المتحدة والدول
الأخرى
القيام به خلال السنوات القليلة الماضية لإحلال
السلام في سوريا أه  اتفاقات إبراهيم
مع المملكة العربية السعودية وبالطبع
القلق بشأن المفاوضات النووية الإيرانية،
كل ذلك يمكن أن يكتسح في
التهديدات العسكرية
والتهديدات الدبلوماسية وبالطبع
خطر مكافحة الإرهاب الذي
نواجهه الآن داخل غزة لذلك كنا
نتحدث أه  منذ أن بدأنا هنا
بشأن قضية الرهائن وكما
أشار نيك روبرتسون، فهي قطعة رئيسية
من النفوذ المحتمل الذي قد
تمتلكه حماس بالنسبة لقوات الدفاع الإسرائيلية حيث
أنهم يفكرون في التعامل مع
تهديد حماس هذا، كيف يأخذ الرهائن
في الاعتبار ما يفعلونه  يمكن وما لا يمكن فعله على
الأرض، هذا كل ما
تبقى لآبي، الحقيقة هي أن العائق الرئيسي أمام
قوات الدفاع الإسرائيلية في العراق
الآن هو أن أي إجراءات
يتخذونها يمكن أن تقابل برد ضد
الرهائن ولذا يمكنك تخيل
هؤلاء الشباب  والنساء هم العراقيون
في قوات الدفاع الإسرائيلية الذين
يشعرون بالقلق من أن أي إجراء يقومون به
يمكن أن يؤدي إلى وفاة أه
رهينة، لذا فإن هذا
سيحد بشدة من أنواع العمليات التي
يقومون بها داخل غزة إذا قرروا
المضي قدمًا  قوات عسكرية كبيرة ولكن
حتى العمليات الخاصة التي تحاول إنقاذ
الرهائن ستكون في
خطر هائل أيضًا خوفًا من أن تؤدي في الواقع إلى
مقتل رهينة،
حسنًا، العميد المتقاعد بالجيش الأمريكي
مارك كيميت، شكرًا لك